okay time for a cell phone
video update or is it vlog do i still
use the term vlog i don't know i don't
listen to cardi b
but uh i know i've uh talked about this
on air uh just wanted to reiterate it
yeah i'm not going to be around
live on the channel in july because i am
undergoing uh some some surgery um
look it's uh i'm good i'll be fine
it's a pretty tough recovery um
without getting any details and i'm
going to the mayo clinic uh uh
there will be a mini documentary
actually coming up in july
uh about it where you'll actually get to
follow me and hopefully have some
footage of the surgery but
long story short they're uh gonna go in
and play some titanium rods through my
chest
i'll explain it more later but i
appreciate the prayers and and well
wishes um
i'm actually looking forward to a
surgery
so you know the recovery sucks uh i know
it's going to be painful
but i'm more so looking forward to the
improvements
uh afterward this is something that i've
lived with for for most well for my
entire life but has you know
kind of gotten worse so yeah just want
to let you know that and i know usually
we we take the entire month of july uh
well
the show is dead we typically all at
level cutter take like two weeks off and
there's two weeks of
of preparation of taping some sketches
of having some
breakout meetings we have to update
equipment and we do that
sometimes for a couple weeks in december
too but actually this july
there'll be quite a bit of content so
i've been since i didn't know how long i
would be gone
for the surgery uh i did devil and
triple taping some days
um but i'm gonna be back august the
first week of august i think it's
the second or the third is that first
monday of august and there should be
somewhere between like four and four and
six pieces of content being uploaded so
i just wanted you guys to to know keep
your notifications on
uh one of them is an ash wednesday round
table with nick depaolo and dave landau
one of them is an ash wednesday with
jason whitlock one of them is a mini
documentary regarding the
the surgery so actually follow me along
kind of the trailer mayo clinic
and i can't remember we were going we
were actually scheduled to tapes and
change my mind
uh this week and then we just got rained
out so
when we come back i know we'll be taping
a few of those so we'll have someone rap
in succession
male shouldn't compete in women's sports
and i very carefully use the term
mail and women's sports so uh yeah
anyway
uh stay tuned we also may just upload
some content that was mug club exclusive
here so you guys kind of see what you
missed in the last couple of months
but uh i i just wanted to say thank you
i've seen some of the comments
i've gotten some of the uh
i want you know sometimes people misuse
the term letters actual letters
some of you are a marvel you send actual
letters don't send them to the right
place
but sometimes they get to me and
sometimes when damn dave landau is on
the road you know people uh give him
stuff to give to me um just so you know
if it's a consumable
uh or perishable well i i appreciate the
gesture i
i won't partake poison and all that
uh so i i've seen the well wishes i
really i really do appreciate it and if
you want to leave a wishes or anything
you can below
don't feel obligated look this is just
one of those things where
um i i explained to you a little bit
what it is you know the lion will say
why are you smoking
my heart is actually great but my heart
doesn't work great the reason my heart
doesn't work great is
long story short because of the
connective tissue disorder i have
and uh my chest is is caving in on my
heart so i've got about
i i i'm at a little more than half
of the blood flow that you guys have
ventricular output from my heart so
it's a mechanical fix um and
i don't know maybe i'll feel like lance
armstrong you know like i'm on epo after
this because i don't know what it's
like to go through life with full blood
flow to me i'm looking forward to it now
looking forward to the pain
the lance armstrong by the way with uh
with with the three balls not the
not the one um
so yeah it's actually it's overall a
positive thing and honestly i've
probably needed a little bit of rest
uh it comes in the form of having my
chest cracked open
but uh since i won't be gone for as long
as i
anticipated uh you'll still have content
in july
uh you won't go a week without something
and uh really appreciate it if uh you
guys want to support you know what we do
of course
uh you can always join my club at
lightworkcredit.com slash mob club 69
for veterans military
active military or students and you know
that's what pays for um
everything we do here you know we're not
monetized on youtube and we keep
sponsorships limited and
health insurance now for the company all
that is uh
you know we're not funded by a we're
funded by mugs
which is representative of actual
viewers like you
you know as opposed to say
foreign caliphate
so we got that going for us
which is nice
i'll see you soon can you hear her
stolen before i leave before i leave
here
can you hear her snoring
[Music]
i don't know if that registers